today on the matt wall show schools in
virginia will soon be expelling students
as young as kindergarten for the crime
of quote malicious misgendering also the
new white house press secretary is black
and gay and expects to be applauded for
it she also happens to be terrible at
her job democrats say it's a racist
conspiracy theory that they hate
so-called whiteness but we'll listen to
their actual words on the subject today
plus eric swalwell brags about being a
terrible parent a tick-tocker attempts
to answer the what is a woman question
but she does it in the form of a poem
enter our daily cancellation we deal
with the new phenomenon known as
land acknowledgements we'll talk about
all of that and more today on the matt
wall show
[Applause]
[Music]
you know to avoid public criticism and
peer pressure would you compromise your
principles to blend in with the crowd or
would you stand for what you believe in
2020 nba rising star jonathan isaac
faced that very question amid pro
basketball's league-wide protest against
racial injustice jonathan became one of
the only players not to kneel for the
national anthem in his new book why i
stand published with the daily wires dw
books jonathan shares how his
experiences and faith shaped who he is
and his perspective on the world so if
you want to hear the story behind the
stand and gain inspiration and strength
to uphold your own convictions pick up a
copy of why i stand by jonathan isaac
out now wherever you buy books
i want to begin by reflecting again on
one moment in the what is a woman
trailer that we played yesterday on the
show one of the people we interviewed
scott nugent is a female who as she says
medically transitioned to appear like a
male but will never actually be a man
now she speaks out now quite bravely
about her own horrific experiences with
medical transition and warns against
most especially the drugging and
mutilation of children in the trailer
which you can watch at what is a
woman.com nugent says it got me at 42
your child doesn't stand a chance and as
i said yesterday you know we should
understand that your child doesn't
understand a chance and it referring to
you know gender ideology
but your child doesn't doesn't stand a
chance it's not meant to be a literal
guarantee that all of our children are
going to be indoctrinated into the trans
cult against our will we can protect our
kids against that and we must
the point is to emphasize just how
powerful the forces aligned against
the youngest generations actually are
we often lament that kids in school for
example are exposed to things that only
adults should be exposed to but it's
actually worse than that they are in
fact subjected to things that even
adults are not subjected to
actually the adults who choose to
subject our kids to these things
don't want to be subjected themselves to
the very same thing so case in point a
mom this week confronted the clark
county school board in las vegas about
pornographic material that her daughter
was forced to wasn't just assigned to
her she was forced to memorize this and
present it to her class
and listen to how the school board
responds though listen to this
i'm going to read you an assignment
given to my
15 year old daughter at a local high
school
this will be horrifying for me to read
to you but that will give you
perspective on
how she must have felt when her teacher
required her to memorize this
and to act it out in front of her entire
class
i don't love you it's not you it's just
i don't like your dick or anything in
that case i cheated joe
i'm
excuse me i i don't thank you so much
for your thank you for your uh comment
forgive me i we're not using profanity
are you
that's relevant
okay the teacher just
required my daughter to read memorize
this and read this pornographic material
excuse me please don't engage with the
audience okay
so please continue your public comment
your your time is you've got one at one
minute and 19 seconds i ask you simply
this is a public meeting i asked for
decorum um and i'm asking
dr jarrah thank you so much dr
if you don't want me to read it to you
what was that like for my 15 year old
daughter to have to memorize
pornographic material
so you hear someone in the audience
first cuts her off and says this is
propaganda
it's probably it is propaganda but it's
the propaganda being given to kids in
school
and immediately after the mother there
at the microphone
uh said what you heard her say at the
end which is if you don't want to hear
it then why are we giving it to kids
they cut her microphone
they the adults on the school board did
not want to have to hear profanity and
sexual vulgarities but they don't mind
if 15 year old kids are exposed to it
so just think about that for a moment
there are things that kids are subjected
to in schools which would be considered
not only inappropriate but potentially
sometimes illegal anywhere else in
society
adults are able to say things to kids in
school make them do things that in any
other context would lead to that adult
being arrested
if you walked up to a child that was
walking down the sidewalk and you you
handed her the material that the mother
in that video was reading you'd go to
jail
but a teacher can assign it as a
mandatory classroom activity
and the school board will take a don't
ask don't tell approach to it i don't
care if the kids have to hear that but
don't make me listen to it they say
no um kids in school aren't being
treated like adults that would be bad
enough the actual situation is worse
here's another example from today fox
news reports the school board of fairfax
county public schools in fairfax
virginia is reviewing updated rules that
could potentially expose students to
suspension or expulsion for quote
maliciously misgendering their peers
based on quote frequency and intensity
you'll worry about the intensity of the
misgendering
the fairfax county public schools
students rights and responsibilities
handbook which will be voted on may 26th
includes in its updated version rules
that make malicious dead naming and
malicious misgendering of classmates a
level four offense which allows for a
suspension of up to five days if
frequency and intensity are present
according to page 19 of the document
using slurs based upon the actual or
perceived gender identity is forbidden
under the rules of the document quote
which includes but is not limited to
malicious dead naming or malicious
misgendering
now malicious misgendering may sound
like the name of a of an indie band but
actually it refers to the crime of using
a grammatically correct pronoun to refer
to a gender confused person
and dead naming of course means using
the name their parents gave them rather
than whatever name they made up for
their new alter ego
this is a level four offense the good
news is that it's not a level five
offense which means that it's not quite
placed on the same level as homicide and
sexual assault so fairfax in this way is
slightly less insane than the school
district in wisconsin that we talked
about yesterday that's charging
three boys with sexual harassment for
failing to refer to a quote-unquote
non-binary student with they them
pronouns
so this what's happening in fairfax is
actually not as bad as what's happening
in other schools
but the bad news is that level four puts
misgendering on the same tier as assault
theft and arson
so you could like set the school on fire
and uh or you could refer to a boy as a
he
and it's you know tomato tomato it's the
same thing
and the even worse news is that students
all the way down to kindergarten
will be subjected and subject to these
rules and then the prescribed penalties
which include lengthy suspicion
suspensions or even expulsion
this puts a moral burden
on little kids in elementary school
that the vast majority of adults have
never had to endure i've never had to
endure
because they're being compelled to lie
under threat of immediate and severe
punishment
i've never quite been in a situation
like that have you
they must choose between the truth
or their academic futures
like it's like a seven-year-old kid is
faced with that
very few adults have shown the resolve
fortitude courage
to stand by the truth on this issue or
any other issue even when the
consequence is merely an unpleasant look
or an uncomfortable interaction
most adults have shown that they will
respect the pronoun
even if they prefer not to simply
because they're afraid of confrontation
they're afraid of awkwardness
there could be nothing else there there
could be no other potential consequence
other than that
and most adults will just go along with
it
how many children will have the strength
to speak the truth retain their sanity
when the consequence will be not only
social alienation but also severe
administrative punishments
now
the rule does stipulate that only
malicious misgendering incidents will uh
be punished and this gives the kids a
little leeway in case they you know make
the mistake of accidentally using proper
grammar
might also give them a little bit of
grace if they
if they have trouble keeping up with
their classmates who have a gender
identity that changes five times a day
but if it's decided that proper grammar
was used intentionally god forbid
then the consequences will be swift and
dire now when i was a kid students with
a demonstrable grasp on the rules of
grammar
were awarded with like high grades and
little encouraging stickers on their
assignments
now those students are expelled
and how will the administration even
know if the misgendering was intentional
or not
well that'll be up to their kangaroo
courts to determine
of course malicious
and intentional are seen as one and the
same here it's been decided that the
only reason why anybody would ever
intentionally use male pronouns when
referring to a male who wants to be a
female is that they're trying to hurt
the person
the possibility that somebody would
misgender i.e correctly gender not
because they want to hurt anybody but
because they value the truth and because
they realize that cooperating with and
affirming confusion only causes more
harm to the confused individual
that possibility is discounted
doesn't exist as far as the fairfax
schools are concerned
now the effect here is first and
foremost of course that kids are
mentally beaten into submission until
they finally accept the tenets of gender
ideology not because they understand the
tenants or believe them but because
they're afraid
understandably afraid and they lack the
energy or the will to deal with the
consequences of not accepting
what they're being told to accept
but another effect
just as intentional but less often
discussed
is that kids are are being turned
against each other
terry schilling of the claremont
institute made this point on twitter
about this story i thought it was a good
point that these kinds of policies are
on top of everything else yet another
way to sow division and suspicion and
resentment
within the student population among the
kids themselves
it's announced from on high that any
student who intentionally fails to use
preferred pronouns
is malicious and deserving of the
harshest possible penalties
this is a message and word of warning
not just to those heretical students
but to all the other kids as well it's a
big red arrow pointed at the heretic
saying these people are bad they hate
you you should hate them too
that's the announcement
don't try to see the best in people
don't give any grace
don't try to understand things from
their perspective oh no not that
no if they don't do what you want them
to do report them to the authorities and
destroy their lives
that's the message
the environment that's fostered
so your kids don't stand a chance well
if they're abandoned to a system like
this
left to their own devices to navigate it
their chances of surviving with their
souls and minds intact may not be zero
but the chances aren't great that's for
certain
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
cryptocurrency may represent the future
of money it's one of the most exciting
investments opportunities to come around
for some time but what about taxes with
an alto crypto ira you can trade crypto
like bitcoin and avoid or defer the
taxes get into investing in crypto and
do it in a tax advantage retirement
account alto's crypto ira is the easy
way to get crypto into an ira trade all
you want without the tax headache create
an account in just a few minutes and
invest with as little as 10 no setup
charges needed there are multiple ways
to fund your account you can
make a cash contribution you could
transfer cash from an existing ira or
you can roll over an old 401k so it's
very easy to do you also have secure
trading 247 through alto's integration
with coinbase there are 80 plus coins
available including bitcoin ethereum and
cardano uh all you gotta do is open an
alto crypto ira account with as little
as ten dollars and uh that means just go
to alto ira.com matt that's
a-l-t-o-i-r-a-dot-com
matt go again to alto ira dot com slash
matt
so the new white house spokeswoman took
over for jen pasaki yesterday had her
very first uh
white house press conference and her
name is karen jean-pair
that's how i'm going to pronounce it
anyway and this is how karen jean pear
introduced herself let's listen
i am obviously acutely aware
that my presence at this podium
represents a few firsts
i am a black gay immigrant woman
the first of all three of those to hold
this position i would not be here today
if it were not for generations of
barriers
barrier breaking people before me
i stand on their shoulders
if if it were not for generations of
very barrier-breaking people before me i
would not be here
but i benefit from their sacrifices i
have learned from their ex excellence
and i am forever grateful to them
representation does matter you hear us
you hear us say this
often in this administration and no one
understands this better than president
biden
well that's a totally normal thing right
it's just uh you know you're getting up
there it's a it's the white house it's a
press conference and the first thing you
do is announce
um your sexual orientation hey just so
you all know um i have sex with women
just in case i just i wanted to we're
sitting here at the white house and i
thought everyone should know that so
here you go
i like how she she's thanking her for
bears
you know
i want to thank all the lesbian press
secretaries that came before me i stand
on the shoulders
of uh lesbian secretaries it's just an
entire mountain of them that i stand
atop
she's truly the the jackie robinson of
gay press secretaries
well never mind actually because uh
jackie robinson was great at his job
and that's the thing we often forget is
that um jackie robinson was great
and that's why he's remembered uh that's
why he achieved everything that he did
he broke
the color barrier
and was great
so he earned his way in and then he
dominated and that's the thing that's
always missing
you know from from these kinds of
conversations when we talk about the
first person the the first person to do
this or that well it used to be
you were celebrated
if you were the first and also great
if you were the first and you sucked at
it then like nobody cares no one's going
to remember that's not an accomplishment
that's actually worse
so if you're gonna be the first to do
something and then be bad at it it'd be
better off if you didn't do it at all
what if jackie robinson had gotten in
there and just and and he was awful
and it flunked out you know couldn't
couldn't hack it in the league
so if i was even tempted to possibly
celebrate you for being the first of any
kind of person to do something you need
to actually be good at it
now in this case
the fact that you're the first gay black
female press secretary is irrelevant i
mean it's neither interesting nor
important
um even if you're good at your job
but i just i hate how this question of
skill has been completely ignored it's
just been ruled out
we're supposed to celebrate people ahead
of time no matter how
no matter if they're good or not
no matter what they actually do
in that position
in fact she then demonstrated that she
certainly um did not get the job because
of her abilities unfortunately so listen
to this exchange where she tries to
explain
why raising taxes will
lower
inflation this is the claim that biden
had made which is that if by raising
taxes it's going to help fix inflation
which is is totally incoherent of course
but um
and it's it's an indefensible
proposition but you're the press
secretary literally your job is to
defend the indefensible especially if
you're the press secretary for joe biden
so let's hear how she does
look you know we have talked about um we
have talked about this this past year uh
about um making sure that the wealthiest
among us are paying their fair share um
and that is important to do and that is
something that uh you know the president
has been you know working on uh every
day when we talk about inflation and
lowering costs and so it's very
important uh that uh you know as we're
seeing costs rise uh as we're talking
about how to you know uh you know build
a america that's safe that's equal for
everyone and doesn't leave everyone
behind that is an important part of that
as well but how does
raising taxes on corporations lower the
cost of gas the cost of a used car the
cost of food for everyday americans so
look i think we encourage those who have
done very well right especially those
who care about climate change uh to
support a fair attack tax code that
doesn't change that doesn't charge
manufacturers workers cops builders a
higher percentage of their earnings that
the most fortunate people in our nation
and not let this this that stand in the
way of reducing energy costs and
fighting this existential problem if you
think about that as an example and to
support basic collective bargaining
rights as well right that's also
important but look it is you know
by not if without having a fair tax code
which is what i'm talking about then all
every like manufacturing workers cops
you know it's not fair for them to have
to pay higher taxes than the folks that
who are who are who are not paying taxes
at all
that's i that's uh that's hard to watch
i mean visibly
rifling through her notes kind of
panicked like what am i supposed to say
here reading lines that have nothing to
do with the question she was asked
because again the question was how does
raising taxes help lower inflation
question isn't about
uh is it is it good to raise taxes is
everybody paying their fair share
whatever nonsense
that's not the question the question is
does it lower inflation because that's
the claim
that joe biden made
and that's her performance now i get
that being press secretary is actually a
very hard job you're constantly lying
you can never give a straight answer to
anything at least that's what the job
has become right
now i think once you finally deadened
and silenced your conscience it becomes
probably easier and if you go into it
with no conscience at all then um it's
it's even easier that was i think jan
pasaki's great advantage
but uh still it's uh
it
that's no excuse
for being that bad at it
now if it were me and i was asked hey
why did the president say that raising
taxes will fix inflation i would just
say well because he was lying and
people don't like paying taxes and so he
was just trying to think of a way to
make it
more appealing to people
and lots of people are stupid and so
they'll buy it
that's the reason
but i wouldn't have the job for very
long so i know you can't you can't say
that i get it
but your job is to say a bunch of stuff
where you're not really saying anything
but it sounds like you're saying
something that's essentially the job
and there's a certain skill
involved there which karen jean-pierre
just doesn't have at all
she was also asked as we move on here
to buffalo she was asked why biden is
going to buffalo
but as we pointed out yesterday did not
go to waukesha and here's her answer to
that
how come the president is visiting
buffalo after a senseless tragedy there
but he couldn't visit waukesha after six
were killed and 61 injured in an attack
on a christmas parade there i mean he's
visited many communities buffalo he was
we you know he was he's able to go
tomorrow to buffalo uh uh before the
trip that is something that was
important for him to do but he has
visited many of many other communities
this is not buffalo is not the first
community sadly that he has to go up to
because of a violent attack so you know
that's not that's not the first one so
he's been to many others
well right no one said that he's never
visited communities before she reminds
me of my kids you know if i'm like hey
luke you didn't clean your room when i
told you to why didn't you clean your
room
daddy i cleared the table yesterday
after dinner
what does it have to do with cleaning
your room though that's not yeah i
understand that you've done chores in
the past i've told you do but that's not
the chore i ask you to do specifically
right now
so in this case she says uh well he's
gone to plenty of communities
he's gone to me he's gone to i mean
dozens and dozens of communities in his
probably hundreds of communities there
are so many communities that joe biden
has been to
now i could list them all but it's just
there's so many i couldn't even listen
well we understand that but that
actually only further um underscores
the point that he didn't go to waukesha
so responding to that by saying oh he
goes out communities all the time he's
always visiting communities
well that just makes it worse don't you
see karen jean-pierre it makes it worse
because he didn't go to waukesha
so he goes to communities all the time
especially ones where there's a some
sort of a
mass attack
didn't go to waukesha why is that
well we know the answer and i know it's
the answer she can't give
but the actual answer is that the
victims were white and so
democrats they just don't care about
that
um speaking of buffalo i want you i want
you to listen to what this reporter says
when
asking karen gene pair about the
so-called great replacement theory just
listen to the uh the words that are used
here very
very telling listen
there's polling that shows one in three
americans believe in some element of
replacement theory
you just spoke in very broad brush
strokes there are there specifics that
this white house is willing to do
willing to take in order to stop this
form of thinking from further seeping
out of the fringe and into the
mainstream
so you know we're going to continue to
call this out
as we have talked about many times the
president at every chance he's had when
we've seen a violent
attack like this that is uh
that is as we you know say with hatred
and racially motivated he calls it out
and and calls it what it is
what are we going to do to stop this
form of thinking
they're not even trying to hide it
are we going to stop there's somebody in
the press asking this by the way how are
we going to stop people from thinking
like this
and thinking like what exactly what is
the form of thinking well it's this uh
it's
the the so-called great replacement
theory and one of the club i want to
play for you on this and then uh and
then i have
a couple
exactly i have some examples in fact of
the great replacement theory that i want
to present to you but first here's chuck
schumer on the floor of the senate
yesterday also railing there are so many
examples we could pull from because this
is this has been
uh the current thing for the democrats
over the last couple days is the the
great replacement theory which they're
accusing republicans of engaging in and
so here's just one example chuck schumer
the floor of the senate railing about it
listen
this is replacement theory in a nutshell
it is dangerous
and a deeply anti-american world view
it is poisoning minds
people's minds who spend hours wandering
the darkest wastelands
of the internet
and let's be clear
it's a message that has also found a
special home
in several right-wing outlets and on one
cable news channel in particular fox
news
in a craven quest
for viewers in ratings
organizations like fox news have spent
years perfecting the craft of stoking
cultural grievance and political
resentment
stoking grievance and resentment is of
course all these people do that is their
entire mo that's their entire political
strategy they have nothing else to offer
they don't do anything but that is just
stoke especially racial grievance and
resentment uh while he accuses everybody
else doing that now the the
what is the theory here
well as i pointed out yesterday
it this this actually is a theory from
the democrats
and their theory
is that
whiteness generally speaking
um
is something that can be and should be
uh mitigated
it like it's it's a disease that's the
theory on the left
is that whiteness is a disease that
needs to be cured
and i mean that in a very literal sense
so i'll just give you one example here
a guy by the name of donald moss wrote a
paper this was just last year wrote a
paper for the journal of the american
psychoanalytic association
and we could put this up there for you
this is just just the abstract of this
paper this is what he writes
and this by the way is totally in
keeping with crt i mean this is
basically crt with a little bit of of uh
psychobabble a little bit of extra
psychobabble added in so this is what
donald moth says
whiteness is a condition
one first acquires and then one has a
malignant parasitic-like condition to
which white people have a particular
susceptibility the condition is
foundational generating characteristic
ways of being in one's body and one's
mind and in one's world parasitic
whiteness
renders its hosts appetites voracious
insatiable and perverse
these deformed appetites particularly
target non-white peoples
once established these appetites are
nearly impossible to eliminate
effective treatment consists of a
combination of psychic and social
historical interventions such
interventions can reasonably aim only to
reshape whiteness's infiltrated
appetites to reduce their intensity
redistribute their aims and occasionally
turn those aims toward the work of
reparation
and then we go forward a little bit and
it says
um
there is not yet
a permanent cure
so this is the
again totally consistent this is not
just some fringe concept totally
consistent with crt this this way of
thinking is there's a reason why it was
published in the psychoanalytic journal
it's all over the psychology
psychology and psychiatry industry
and he is quite literally saying that
whiteness is a parasitic condition for
which it is necessary that we find a
permanent cure
you find this in the media too uh here's
this from this is jennifer rubin at the
washington post
um somewhat infamous tweet from last
year
and she was responding to census data
which which which showed at the time and
as we've seen this in in successive uh
census reports the number of white
people falls for the first time so she's
responding to a headline which says
census data shows widening diversity
number of white people falls for the
first time jennifer rubin's response a
more diverse more inclusive society this
is fabulous news
now we need to prevent minority white
rule
so
she is responding
specifically to a headline this is the
the number of white people falls for the
first time
she says fabulous news
now if for some reason it's not
immediately obvious
why this that's a horrific thing to say
all you have to imagine is if the
headline had said number of black people
falls
and then someone had responded and said
fabulous news
so
if anyone in media responded that way to
um the hypothetical headline saying that
the number of black people falls that
person will be done forever like their
career is over it's destroyed there
would be
100 agreement among everyone everywhere
that that is very racist and it would be
of course
like if you're cheering
for the for the for the population of a
certain race
to dwindle
that's
that's racist like i can't think of a
more racist thing than that
and this is what you get on the left
um another example this is from
hollywood producer morgan j freeman we
have a couple of tweets from him not to
be confused with not that morgan freeman
not the fan not the famous one the
different one
um he says this is just today or
yesterday he tweeted this being
anti-racist starts by admitting
whiteness is a disease
whiteness is a dominant cultural space
with enormous political significance
with the purpose to keep others on the
margin
so it's a disease whiteness is disease
we got to get rid of it
so on and so forth now
um
so this is the game they play first of
all again the theory
that whiteness is a disease a problem
and we have to minimize it mitigate it
replace it
um that is the theory on the left
and
if you notice it
if you simply notice what they're saying
and then you point to it and say hey did
you hear what that person just said then
all of a sudden you're the conspiracy
theorist
this is the game they play
um to great effect in fact
they just scare people
into uh
into silence
and they create this environment where
they can of course say whatever they
want
uh but then they also get to decide
you know they could just say what they
want and uh but if if in certain
circumstances they might not want you to
quote them they might not want you to
notice what they're doing even when
they're explicit about it and so they
get to decide
eric swalwell had some thoughts about
about the buffalo massacre as well let's
put this tweet up there he says
my four-year-old just facetime to ask
what i'm doing to help the people in
buffalo and why did the bad man do this
absolutely gutting this could not be his
normal it's time to ban assault weapons
hashtag end gun violence now there's a
follow-up we'll put it up in a second
but
this is this is of course the meme
that eric swalwell is is uh is doing
here which is the common things you find
especially on the left that like no
matter how often this is relentlessly
mocked they keep doing it where they put
word they put their own words into the
mouths of their of their children and
then they do this oh my child just came
up to me and
said this doesn't matter how often we
make fun of this they just keep on doing
it
and the thing is very often when they
make up these stories about what their
kids have said
we're actually doing them a favor by
assuming that they're making it up
because if they're not making it up then
it means that they're abusive means that
they're either they're liars or their
terrible parents
so it's almost like for your own sake
i'm going to assume i'm gonna give you
the benefit of doubt and assume your kid
didn't say that
like like in this case
your four-year-old why would your
four-year-old know about a mass shooting
in buffalo
why would you tell your four-year-old
that i have a five-year-old at home it
would never occur to me
to
turn the news on and say hey hey come
come on in here son and watch this
there's a there's a mass shooting in
buffalo let me tell you all about
it now the thing about being a very
young kid is that you
if you if you have good parents anyway
you can just be a kid
and you don't have to live
um
with the awareness of of all of the most
horrible things that are happening in
the world there's there'll be time for
that later on in life
but not right now
so a lot of people accused eric swalwell
of making this up and he wanted us to
know that he didn't make it up so he uh
he followed up with put the follow tweet
up there
i love the uh the no four-year-old would
ask this takes you're an absolute denial
if you think our kids aren't watching
the horrors that we're allowing
and then he and then he shows the text
message exchange whereas i guess it's
his wife
and it's kind of confusing because
his wife texts me he wants to know if
you're going to help the family of the
people who died at the supermarket
massacre and there's a picture of a kid
watching the news watching cnn
but the kid has a bow
in the hair and is wearing a dress
so is eric swalwell dressing his son up
like a girl or is that his daughter who
knows i mean i wouldn't put it past him
of course
so he's dunking on us by
by
he's sort of debunking our claims that
he's lying by saying no no i actually am
a terrible parent and i do tell my
four-year-old
about these kinds of things
okay well have it your way swallow
you're a terrible parent then i'm i'm
fine believing that
totally believable
all right uh one of the clip i want to
play for you on a more positive note
here's republican senator james lankford
yesterday on florida senate
uh making a point that may sound
familiar if you listen to this show but
still an important point let's listen
you know it's federal law right now that
we protect turtle eggs
turtles
if you destroy a turtle egg it's a
federal offense with a very big fine
if you destroy an eagle egg
it's a very big offense with a federal
fine do you find that odd and i'm just
in dialogue with this person do you find
that odd
that in federal law we protect an eagle
egg acknowledging that's an eagle inside
that egg and we protect a turtle egg
saying we acknowledge that's a turtle
inside that egg
but we allow the destruction of children
into my shock
they responded
will turtles and eagles are endangered
so they should be protected
and i'm called the extremist
uh it's
this is a point that should be i'm glad
he brought it up on the floor of the
senate because this is a point that uh
should be made that we should that we
should keep making because especially
now we could talk about the endangered
species as we did on the show but um
the most important thing to bring up is
like no it's not just it's not just it's
bad enough if
turtles that are walking around in the
sand you know if they're protected more
than babies are which they are but it's
it's also in their embryonic form
they are not only protected but legally
recognized that's the point here
a an embryonic turtle is legally
recognized as a turtle
and yet an embryonic human
is not legally recognized as a human
that's the point
and so you can't escape that point by
saying well turtles are endangered
so they're endangered so they
does that change what they what they
fundamentally biologically are
because they're endangered then they
they still count as turtles when they're
in their habitat phase but but humans
that doesn't make any sense
and also just another point on this
endangered thing
aren't we told that human beings are
also endangered
i'm pretty sure i've been
i've been reliably informed by
alexandria cortez and many others that
we actually not only are we endangered
but we have
i don't know they said it was 12 years
and then it keeps changing but it's in
fact it it interestingly enough it's all
it always seems to be about 10 to 12
years is the amount of time we have to
live left on this planet
and then but it's always 10 years in the
future
so it's 10 years in the future right now
and then we're going to get to 10 years
from now it'll be it'll be a 2032 and
we'll still we still have 10 years left
but one way or another we have 10 years
left because of climate change
so we're endangered also aren't we
but that's again kind of irrelevant
because the point it's just a it's a
logical contradiction here
does uh does a a creature
at its earliest phases of existence
is that is that a is it a different
category
is it like almost a different species or
is it the same species the same category
just in a in its earliest phase of
development
which is it
that's the question that they have to
confront all right one other thing i
want to play for you this is a before we
get to the comment section this is a
tick tock video that somebody sent to me
um
and here is
someone attempting to answer the
question
of what is a woman
and not only they're answering it but
they're doing it
thankfully in the form of poetry so
let's listen to this
you know what question really frustrates
me
what is a woman
so i wrote a poem
what is a woman
how do you define are we the sum of our
parts or is it more refined
must we be feminine or dress all in pink
is it how we dress and act or how we
think
is it our bodies that make us a she
is it our dna our biology
yet there are women who have no uterus
no breasts who cannot give birth do we
call them less
so it's not nature organs or dress
how do we define what a woman is best
a woman is someone who decides who she
is
it's not an answer on some imaginary
quiz
some women are strong some women feel
small
some women are so hurt they feel nothing
at all
some women are alone some women are
mothers some women are vengeful some
women are lovers
womanhood is more than a box we fit in
we don't owe an answer to questions
asked with a smug grin
we owe no explanation we aren't here to
appease we are women we will be
who we please
hope you guys liked it love and
i wish that someone
when we were shooting the film had had
uh
broken out into poetry for me because
that would have been great that's the
one thing i told you there's a lot of
stuff in this film
a lot of shocking moments but no i
didn't get any poetry so i'm a little
bit upset about that uh maybe we can add
that to a credit sequence or something i
don't know but
um
that's that's her attempt at an answer
and it is even though she she takes the
poetry approach it is
it's exactly what everyone does of
course where she's just adding a whole
bunch of words
but then it comes down and you're
waiting and you're waiting
i don't know about you but i was on the
i was on the edge of my seats there uh
metaphorically anyway listening like
okay it's all the poetry and the rhyming
very nice
are we going to get to an answer at the
end we get the last stanza are you going
to finally have the answer
and uh but at the very end it's no
there's no answer
so all of that to come down to the
conclusion of i have no idea i don't
know what a woman is
a woman is uh was anything they please
that doesn't help us at all
it's also
of course not
true
okay you can't
no nobody can be literally anything they
want to be so but putting that aside for
a second it doesn't actually answer the
question
so a lot of dancing around it but at
least you danced around in the form of a
rhyme so i can appreciate that
well it's finally happened the fed is
realizing the dire straits that our
economy is in thanks to our loose
monetary policy apparently you can't
just spend trillions
every year with no repercussions who
would have thought now to play ketchup
the fed has been raising rates and plans
to plans to raise them seven times this
year alone you're already starting to
see those ripple effects in the housing
market as people's buying power
diminishes have you considered what
could happen in the stock market if our
economy stalls out
don't wait till that happens don't wait
till it's too late take some of your
profit from the stock market now and
solidify them with gold from birch gold
throughout history gold has maintained
its value better than any other
investment in the entire world that's
how stable and secure it is text walsh
to 98 98 98 for a free zero obligation
info kit on holding gold in a tax
sheltered retirement account join the
thousands of happy birch gold customers
with countless five-star reviews and an
a-plus rating with the better business
bureau i trust the professionals at
birch gold you should too all you got to
do again is text walsh to 98 98 98 and
secure the gains that you've made while
you can
let's get now to the comment
sweet baby section
um
let's see angela says i want to become a
daily wire member just for your movie
matt well we appreciate that and uh lots
of people telling me that that they want
to become a daily wire member to watch
this film and i hope
for the sake of my own feelings that
you're actually doing it so go to what
is a woman because it's gonna hurt my
feelings if you don't go to what is
woman.com and sign up and become a
member today um
let's see scott says okay matt i'll
admit that the plane with the what is
one banner flying behind it was
impressive but i have to mention the
fact that i didn't see a single ash
breasted tit tyrant flying around that
day how could you possibly still believe
that the ash breasted tit tyra community
is not threatened by habitat loss well
they uh
if you saw the the footage of the
women's march you you saw plenty of the
ash breasted tit timer it turns out that
they're flightless birds they're much
like penguins uh they don't fly
and they they in fact have the physique
of a of large like large emperor
penguins
it turns out
um
stevo says in reference to today's
canceling i'm an immigrant from
australia i've been here for 20 years
and call myself an american
here's what i get asked all the time
do you know crocodile dundee
are you having a nice vacation or
welcome to america the interesting part
is it's usually the libs that ask me why
on earth i would want to leave australia
for the u.s conservatives will say
australia is a place they'd like to
visit i usually answer the former with
for freedom americans are the most
welcoming people on the planet stop with
the nonsense what on earth is wrong with
people taught what is what on earth is
wrong with talking about where you're
from
have some fun with it another thing i
get asked is if kangaroos hop down the
city streets i always go with yes and
add in that if you see a red kangaroo
you may be able to hitch a ride on it as
they're 16 feet tall
that is unless it hasn't killed you
first yeah but do kangaroos just hop
down the street in australia that is i'd
like an actual answer to that question
yeah this is this is the correct
uh
attitude
that any human being should have and i
say this i mean i was thinking about
this yesterday we did the daily
cancellation about these leftist
immigrants complaining when people ask
them where they're from
and i'm saying how absurd that is to be
to be uh offended by it
i say this as someone who who infamously
is not a big fan of small talk but even
though i'm not a big fan of it see
that's that's a perfect example i'm not
a big fan of it
but i'm not offended when someone
attempts it
and i also realize that my
issues with small talk those are my
issues so i don't have the right to
actually be offended that anyone would
dare try to strike up a small talk
conversation that's my own hang up
which i'm entitled to and which i will
cling to but i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
make it your problem
and especially if you're an immigrant to
this country
and you're welcome in this country
and people are showing an interest in
where you're from
and they want to know about your the
culture where you're from and the
country from like
how about have a little bit of gratitude
for the fact that you've been welcomed
and people are taking an interest
would you actually prefer that you come
to this country and then you're just
ignored
nobody cares
no well of course as we discussed
yesterday they
the people that have this attitude and
this is this is the way the left
approaches these issues
which is that you know sometimes they're
in the mood to talk about themselves and
their identity and sometimes they aren't
and you're supposed to know ahead of
time and read their mind and that's the
way that's supposed to work the value of
the minivan pickup sedan or whatever you
drive probably appreciated significantly
last year take care of your automotive
investment and keep more of your money
by buying the auto parts you need to
maintain and repair your vehicle at
rockauto.com rockauto.com only sells
auto parts and related tools
they've been doing it for over 20 years
their unique intuitive catalog includes
photos specs and installation tips that
make it really easy to choose the
correct parts for your specific vehicle
and then install them as well so they
got all of it right there on their
website they not only have the auto
parts you need but we'll give you a
selection of trusted name brands to
choose from you can pick breaks that
match how you use your vehicle whether
that's for towing racing or just
commuting to work you can get suspension
exhaust air conditioning other kits that
provide all the parts you need for a
successful repair rockauto.com has lots
of parts that you might expect would
only be available at car dealerships if
they're available at all uh parts like
the fan inside your seat that cools your
tush so yeah
you got to put something else there so i
stopped reading that that cools your
tush
rockauto.com prices are always reliably
low that means they do not change prices
based on what the market will bear like
many airlines and marketplace sites do
their prices make it affordable for
customers to keep their daily drivers
and classics safely on the road so go to
rockauto.com for your auto parts and
write walsh in there how did you hear
about us box so they know that i sent
you also
leading up to the two-year anniversary
of george floyd's death and the radical
worldwide repercussions that followed
canis owens has taken her bold lens to
the people and places that ignited the
violent and racially divided aftermath
joined candace as she goes beyond what
you've been told by the media to bring
the truth to light and expose the
greatest lie ever told the trailer for
this explosive documentary drops tonight
at 8 pm central time on candace owen's
show the greatest lie ever told george
floyd and the rise of blm is only
available to daily wire members so
subscribe today at thegreatestlie.com
and tune in tonight to be the first to
catch the exclusive trailer you don't
want to miss it now let's get to our
daily cancellation
[Music]
so a writer by the name of michelle
psycho highlights what she says is the
worst land acknowledgement she's ever
seen now for those who are unfamiliar
with this cutting edge innovation in the
field of white guilt a land
acknowledgement is something like an act
of contrition that a catholic might say
after confessing his sins to the priest
except in this case the act of
contrition is being offered to some
randomly selected group of indians who
lived on the land in question at some
arbitrary point in the past
land acknowledgments are meant to
acknowledge that we are allegedly on
tribal land so needless to say
talking about the worst land
acknowledgement it's like discussing the
most unpleasant porta potty you've ever
been in i mean these aren't there aren't
any good ones they're just varying
degrees of sickening the one presented
here for consideration is from
vancouver island university and it says
vancouver island university acknowledges
that we are on the traditional and
unseated territory of the
oh boy
the snooni
maksu well how do you do that that's xw
how do you pronounce that
anyway territory of the snooni muksu
people and we thank them for allowing us
to live laugh love and learn here
okay i take it back that is probably the
worst
if only the pioneers who conquered these
lands with their blood and sweat and
toil could have known that a few hundred
years hence their descendants would be
groveling before these indian tribes and
whispering to them thank you for
allowing us to live laugh and love and
do yoga here our ancestors probably
would have just turned around and went
home and said it's not worth the effort
why bother bleeding and dying for a
civilization that will one day be
inherited by the most embarrassing
obsequious effeminate weaklings to ever
live on planet earth perhaps that's the
point of all this
the left is punishing their ancestors by
becoming everything their ancestors
would hate
in fact come to think of it that is
exactly the point but we're getting
ahead of ourselves michelle provides
another fund contender for the worst
land acknowledgement this one from the
washington state department of
corrections it reads
the washington state department of
corrections acknowledges that its
facilities offices and operations are on
the ancestral lands and customary
territories of indigenous peoples tribes
and nations corrections is it thanks
gives thanks to the tribes for caring
for these lands since time immemorial
and honors its ongoing connection to
these communities past present and
future we welcome the opportunity to
collaborate with the indigenous
populations and communities and strive
to work with our tribal partners to
improve the lives of indigenous people
and non-indigenous neighbors throughout
the state
okay you're you're a prison so just calm
down here
but these acknowledgments also come in
video form lucky for you for instance
last week the aspen ideas festival
kicked off with this quirky little
disclaimer listen to this
truth and acknowledgement are the
foundation to healing and transformation
we begin this effort today by
acknowledging that we are in the
ancestral lands of native nations
including the taino the colusa the
tequesta and today the sovereign and
unseated homelands of the seminole tribe
of florida and the mikasuki tribe of
indians of florida
our communities in ways have existed
long before the united states
we have survived attempted takeovers
the indian removal act under andrew
jackson
three seminal wars between 1814 and 1858
being hunted with bloodhounds rounded up
like cattle and forced on the trail of
tears
okay the trail of tears started in 1830
so that's nearly 200 years ago
my ancestors were dying in the potato
famine around that time
but you don't hear me complaining about
it
if you're carrying around grievances
that date back two
centuries
to a time before you or your parents or
your parents parents or your parents
parents parents grandparents parents
were alive then that tells me that you
have these grievances
because you want them
they're an emotional tool that you like
to use
here's the thing
most human beings on earth today if they
trace their lineage back 200 years
we'll find that their ancestors endured
all manner of unspeakable horrors
deprivations and sufferings but only
some of us
go around talking about it all the time
only some of us feel that our ancestors
struggles must be acknowledged to us
as if we were the ones who suffered
those things
but that wasn't even as bad as the
acknowledgment that now as of last year
is played before every home game for the
chicago blackhawks hockey team listen to
this
the chicago blackhawks acknowledge
that the team its foundation
and the spaces we maintain work and
compete within
stand upon the traditional homelands of
the miami sauk muskoki ho chunk
menomonie
and the council of the three fires the
ojibwe odawa and potawatomi nations
we understand that this land holds
immense significance for its original
stewards the native nations
and the peoples of this region
we would also like to recognize that our
team's namesake sauk war leader
blackhawk serves as a continuous
reminder of our responsibility to the
native american communities we live
amongst and draw inspiration from
yes it's very important that we pay
homage to the ho-chunk people before a
hockey game i can't tell you how many
times i've been sitting down to watch a
sporting event and thought to myself you
know
it's not fair that we're all enjoying
ourselves here and just completely
ignoring the ho-chunks uh it's just i've
said it so many times like it's my my
family they're sick of me saying because
i always say it
they also of course had to pay deference
to uh sauk war leader blackhawk who was
an indian warlord born in the mid 1700s
it'd be quite rude to have a hockey
match without mentioning an indian
warlord from 250 years ago obviously
as a war leader blackhawk um
would have led raiding parties now
do you know what raiding parties did
they weren't throwing parties as we
think of them today i can tell you that
okay these weren't birthday parties they
were raiding parties and raiding meant
stealing from and terrorizing other
tribes often killing their men
kidnapping and raping their women and
their children okay that's what indian
tribes did
so when you hear about an indian warlord
that's what he did
this is how they lived
and of course you know we're obsessed
with problematic uh we we we gotta we
gotta sift through the lives of all the
historical figures tear down the statues
we're worried about problematic
historical figures but the only
historical figures we're still allowed
to honor
are indian warlords from 200 years ago
that raped and killed children
this is what happened in indian tribes
it was the case everywhere without
exception
they stole from each other they killed
they kidnapped they conquered and so on
over and over again century upon century
this is one of the many reasons why this
whole
land acknowledgement thing is is
ludicrous
whose land is it who are we supposed to
be acknowledging
just the most recent tribe to occupy it
before white people showed up but that
tribe stole it from another and that one
from a different tribe and on and on
stretching back into the unknown and
unrecorded pest this is not what about
ism this is first of all a simple
historical reality that needs to be
acknowledged speaking of acknowledgments
it's also a logical problem for the for
the white guilt brigade
if this is not really our land
if we occupy it illegitimately because
we conquered it then the same must be
said of whatever tribe we took it from
and of whatever tribe they took it from
etcetera the only way to escape this
problem is to suggest that the white man
should be held to a higher standard
but why is that
the only way to justify a higher moral
standard for the white men is the claim
that the white man is inherently morally
superior but i'm pretty sure that's not
what they mean to say or what they want
us to take away from this
which means then that the same
historical standard applies to everybody
which completely destroys the basis for
all this groveling and apologizing
this land was soaked in the blood of
conquest long before anyone with white
skin ever stepped foot on these shores
the white man joined the fray joined the
fight didn't start it
or at least of all invent the whole
concept
after all what does the word indigenous
even mean
according to the collins dictionary it
means quote people or things that belong
to the country in which they're found
rather than coming there or being
brought there from another country
okay well that means that either
no one is indigenous here or we all are
because everybody who lives here now
every no exceptions here everyone
who lives
in the americas
is descended from a group that came here
at some point in the past
period
now your ancestors may have came here
come here a thousand years ago they may
have come here 200 years ago two years
ago
but we all came here a nation of
immigrants isn't that what the left
always likes to say now it's not
actually true because the european
settlers came here before it was an
actual nation i mean they came when it
was unsettled wilderness which means
they weren't technically immigrants but
we did all come here that's true
that doesn't mean that we can't or
shouldn't defend and control our borders
no because once you claim and settle a
territory you have to defend it
if you won't or you can't it will cease
to exist
if you have land that you won't or can't
defend
you will not have it for very long
that's the law of history that's the way
of the world the indian tribes played
this same game and understood the rules
it's only we modern people who are
stupid and shallow enough to be
scandalized by it
by the way that land acknowledgement
from the university has now um
necessitated its own acknowledgement of
the sins committed by the
acknowledgement because the university
posted after that they said we thank
michelle psycho for bringing to our
attention an unofficial land
acknowledgment on our website we
apologize to those who are negatively
impacted by this language
apologizing for an apology
and if anybody anybody was negatively
impacted by the apology for the apology
they'll no doubt apologize for the
apology for the apology they are stuck
now in a self-perpetuating cycle of
groveling
a vortex of cringe
this is the inevitable end result
it's where it always leads
and it's why land acknowledgments and
all who give them
are today cancelled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavo vadowsky
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by robbie dantzler
our audio is mixed by mike coromina and
hair and makeup is done by cherokee
heart the matt wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
the new white house press secretary
humiliates herself during her first day
on the job democrats exploit the buffalo
massacre and the fight for the future of
the gop plays out in pennsylvania check
it out on the michael knowles show